vi è mai capitato di ricevere la visita
dei ladri è una mattina come tante
vi siete svegliati lavati vestiti
preparati per uscire
avete scambiato qualche parola con
vostra moglie per decidere che andrà a
prendere i bambini oppure portato il
cane a fare una passeggiata come al
solito o magari vi siete preoccupati di
quella riunione che avrete al pomeriggio
o magari avete ancora telefonato
all'amica quella con cui fate di solito
l'aperitivo proprio il giovedì sera e vi
siete chiusi la porta alle spalle
tranquilli sicuri che quel posto così
vostro così intimo sarà lì ad aspettarvi
alla sera così come lo avete lasciato
sarà lì dopo una lunga giornata di
lavoro dopo che sarà stato magari
faticosa arrivare fino alla sera
e invece quando rientrate non è così
la porta è leggermente socchiusa la
aprite con un po di cautela gli armadi
sono spalancati i cassetti rovesciati a
terra la biancheria da tutte le parti
anche quel vaso che vi piaceva tanto
propri all'ingresso frantumato a terra
ecco il cancro al seno per la
femminilità con per una casa a ricevere
la visita dei ladri
improvvisamente è tutto toccato e tutto
frantumato e tutto confuso non è più
niente di quello che avete lasciato al
mattino e succede di colpo
se siete dopo che hai deciso di fare
un'ecografia perchè arrivi una grande
olina che non ti convince va tanto forse
hai ricevuto a casa un depliant che
diceva è il mese della prevenzione
tu vai e fai un'ecografia è un giorno
come un altro ti si è svegliata sei
uscita ti sei preparata ma l'ecografista
ti guarda e ti dice farei dei controlli
più approfonditi sono entrati i ladri in
quel momento lì non sai più cosa fare il
tuo mondo è completamente ribaltato il
tuo mondo è pieno di parole che ti fanno
paura e la tua femminilità è ribaltata
perché il cancro al seno colpisce li
colpisce dove noi donne siamo convinti
di essere donne di rappresentare quello
che siamo
colpisce il nostro seno che è il simbolo
della femminilità ci sono film giornali
fotografie la donna
la bellezza di quello che è il suo seno
colpisce i tuoi capelli la chemioterapia
non perdona facilmente i capelli li
perderai e colpisce ancora più
profondamente perché la terapia romana
ormonale che ti consigliano se sei una
donna giovane se una donna fertile
facilmente ti mette di fronte al fatto
che forse figli non avrai più e allo
stesso tempo sicuramente ti procurerà
una menopausa anticipata quindi tutto
quello che il tuo mondo viene
completamente capovolto viene circondata
dalle parole che sono parole che fanno
paura
parole parole di cui non aveva mai
sentito parlare prima recidiva
mastectomia quadrantectomia radioterapia
tutte cose che pensavi riguardassero
qualcun altro
e tu invece sei lì in mezzo questo a
questa confusione in questa lavatrice di
parole che fanno paura
parole quindi non forme non cose
concrete con cui puoi fare la guerra e
poi che cos'è questa cosa che è dentro
di me e che forse io ho creato allora in
quel momento li avresti bisogno di
qualcosa che ti faccia bene delle parole
che nutrano che ti facciano stare meglio
e non possono essere parole qualunque
perché le parole qualunque non danno
nessuna consolazione
le mie parole di luce le mie parole
belle le mie parole creative le ho
incontrate con una donna con luisa
morniroli oggi a un'amica era una donna
che prima di me un anno prima aveva
attraversato la mia stessa avventura
lei mi ha incontrato e con quella
saggezza che sa soltanto che ha fatto un
percorso come il tuo mi ha insegnato
parole come comprensione come
compassione ma nel senso buono del
prendersi cura di qualcun altro come
femminilità ritrovata come vita nuova e
tutte queste parole sono state molto
importanti hanno creato un legame che
andato molto al di là di quello che è
stato il momento difficile
allora quando luisa mi ha chiesto di
diventare testimonial di un suo progetto
fotografico in cui le donne che avevano
avuto il tumore al seno si mettevano
invece in gioco per aiutare le altre
donne mettendo la loro faccia nella loro
migliore versione con il loro sorriso
con quella femminilità ritrovata dopo
mesi veramente faticosi non ho potuto
che accettare ma anche a rilanciare gli
ho detto perché a queste immagini
bellissime in cui ci ha fatto veramente
diventare tra belle molto più belle che
come eravamo al naturale non uniamo
delle parole che diano forma a quella
che è stata una paura e diano invece
bellezza a quello che queste donne sono
diventate abbiamo costruito così un
progetto insieme di fotografie e di
ritratti a parole perché le parole
creano le parole sono potentissime
creano delle nuove realtà e non solo la
prima a dirlo a inventarlo ne andiamo a
prenderci un libro abbastanza noto a
tutti che il libro della genesi lo
stesso creatore nel momento in cui
decise di fare il cielo e la terra non
fece niente di strano non sbatte agli
occhi non batte le mani non l'hanno
nemmeno un pensiero di vino le scritture
dicono addio disse sia luce e lì e luce
fu
perché la parola crea disse mi avrebbe
potuto fare qualsiasi cosa
quella forza del pensiero ma invece
preferì dire perché le parole creano
mondi le parole creano storie le parole
creano una realtà che noi possiamo
confrontare con cui noi possiamo
confrontarci storie vi siete mai chiesti
perché ci piacciono le storie perché da
bambini ci facciamo raccontare 30 volte
la storia di cappuccetto rosso 50 volte
quella di biancaneve o storie più
recenti
vedo le mie nipoti leggono storie che io
non conoscevo neanche male leggo il cell
e se li fanno leggere raccontare
raccontare perché le storie sono piccoli
universi circoscritti dove noi sappiamo
quanto park dove iniziamo e dove finiamo
le storie sono rassicuranti le storie
non possono avere un altro finale anno
quello e se coi bambini fate attenzione
e provate a cambiare il finale sono
molto attente viri portano subito sul
sulla riga giusta perché è così
le storie sono dei piccoli mondi e noi
piccoli mondi cosa che non è la nostra
vita di cui non sappiamo nel bene e nel
male il finale ci rassicurano molto
allora perché non raccontiamo non
raccontare la nostra storia come forma
di bellezza e di sicurezza e di
ritrovamento di noi stessi
quello che abbiamo fatto con queste
meravigliose donne
e stato proprio quello prendere le loro
storie al di là di quella che era la
malattia a trovare le loro parole di
luce e costruire dei mondi delle storie
nuove le storie hanno un potere
potentissimo e lo sperimento lo potrete
sperimentare anche voi esercitandovi con
un qualche sistema che vi insegnerò in
questi brevi momenti insieme le storie
triplicano il tempo innanzitutto quando
ci balena un'intuizione in testa
qualcosa un pensiero un ricordo un
momento che ci sembra caro che si sembra
valga la pena di riportare di conservare
per noi
poi il tempo si raddoppia nel momento in
cui prendiamo carta e penna se siamo dei
tradizionali in questo gesto molto
morbido e anche artistico della
scrittura
gli consegniamo una forma diamo le
nostre parole una forma ma anche se ci
mettiamo alla tastiera ormai siamo tutti
digitali quindi anche la tastiera e un
gesto che ci fa prendere un tempo per
noi è il terzo modo in cui le storie ci
regalano il tempo è perché quando le
rileggeremo fra un mese sei mesi un anno
quegli stessi pensieri avranno un'altra
vita un altro volto si erano pensieri
felici ci riporteranno a quel momento
felice ci faranno sorridere se erano
pensieri cupi pensieri di cui avevamo
paura
molto probabilmente non ne avremo più
sarà qualcosa che abbiamo già superato e
ce lo potremmo lasciare alle spalle le
storie riescono ad archiviare e
archiviando quello che non ci serve
possiamo sicuramente fare spazio al
nuovo alle cose nuove che possiamo
mettere a nuovi ricordi a noi momenti a
nuova vita
questo abbiamo fatto con queste donne
abbiamo cercato le loro parole
le loro parole luminose loro parole
creative e abbiamo creato dei ritratti
di quelle che loro erano abbiamo trovato
parole che le rappresentassero che
rappresentassero i loro sogni
alcune di loro non si ricordavano
nemmeno più in che cosa erano brave
perché poi nella vita noi ci
dimentichiamo le cose che ci piacciono
davvero
e invece sì siamo proprio prese il tempo
per ricordarci chi siamo
se io chiedessi a voi adesso in questo
momento chi sei
chi siete chi sei tu
molto probabilmente ci troveremo a dire
quello che facciamo quasi tutti di
fronte alla domanda tu chi sei o quando
ci presentiamo raccontiamo quello che
facciamo
vi assicuro che molti non si ricordano
neanche di dire il proprio nome
tantissimi si nascondono dietro invece a
quello che è il loro ruolo sociale madre
moglie e marito figlio oppure quello che
il loro ruolo professionale o avaro vari
stereotipi ma chi siamo veramente
cos'è quel qualcosa che ci rende unici
perché non decidiamo ogni tanto di
dedicarci il tempo per ricordarci
davvero chi siamo
e chiaro che non è così facile se lo
facciamo con la testa ci andiamo a
rifugiare sempre nelle solite scappatoie
ma ci sono piccoli modi che ciascuno di
noi può mettere in atto per provare a
ritrovare chi è uno dei modi potrebbe
essere affidandosi ai sensi alla
sensorialità i sensi sono i nostri
canali aperti verso il mondo noi
pensiamo che tutto ci arrivi dalla mente
in realtà tutto ci arriva dai sensi la
mente il compito che è quello di
discriminare di dividere di scegliere
quello che mi va a quello che non mi va
a quello che gradisco quello che non
gradisco scegliere sceglie soltanto ma
l'esperienza la faccia attraverso il
tatto attraverso l'olfatto la vista
l'udito mi arrivavo alten direttamente e
noi ci dimentichiamo spesso di avere dei
sensi non ci facciamo assolutamente
attenzione quindi esploriamo con tutti i
sensi quella che la nostra realtà
esplorare questi significa anche
togliersi e liberarsi un po dal nostro
io giudicante da quella parte che ci
dice sempre che non siamo bravi se
facessimo un altro esperimento qua e vi
dicessi vabbè adesso prendiamo carta e
penna e ciascuno scrive qualcosa dopo il
50 per cento di voi dice no ma io non so
scrivere
e non è vero questa è la più grande
bugia che ci possiamo dire tutti
sappiamo scrivere
abbiamo imparato sicuramente in prima
elementare se eravamo dei bambini
precoci anche a 45 anni scrivevamo già
qualcosa
la scrittura non è nient'altro che
trascodifica re sulla carta mettere
sulla carta mettere sullo schermo di un
computer
le parole e lei siamo pieni di parole
siamo pieni di parole ogni giorno e
quindi è soltanto questione di
trasformare la scrittura non in un
momento di difficoltà ma in un momento
di condivisione con noi stessi di quello
che siamo e di quello che vogliamo
diventare i metodi sono tantissimi
ognuno può trovare il suo io vi ho
parlato dei sensi non può farlo
attraverso la meditazione si ricava un
piccolo spazio in cui la mente
finalmente si libera e posso veramente
provare a cominciare a pensare a cosa
veramente sono io cosa veramente piace a
me cosa è veramente la mia dimensione
sperimentarsi e ritrovarsi se non è la
meditazione la vostra strada potrebbe
essere un lavoro manuale qualcosa di
manuale vi ricordate quando da bambini
giocavamo con il pongo con il das con
queste con queste mescole appiccicose
con cui costruivamo i mondi
ecco molto spesso dedicarsi a qualche
cosa di manuale assolutamente anche
astratto per qualcuno invece può essere
che so io sbattere le uova per fare una
buona torta però dedicarsi a qualcosa di
concreto ci permette veramente di
liberare i pensieri e di provare ad
andare a contattare quella che è la
nostra identità un pochino un po più
intima un pochino più strutturata quindi
affidarci un po a questa possibilità di
andare a navigare dentro noi stessi nei
nostri ricordi ma anche a scandagliare
quelle che sono le nostre emozioni
quindi ricordare pacificare con quello
che abbiamo detto non ci spaventa più
perché già successo e ricostruire
rinascere con qualcosa di nuovo
quello che hanno fatto loro e stato
proprio questo io ve lo presento adesso
e sono daniela alessandra caterina
roberta paola elisa simona cristina mary
ed elisabetta loro sono le prime dieci
donne con cui abbiamo
ho fatto questa esperienza di mettersi
in gioco e di farsi un ritratto di
ritrovarsi
all'inizio erano molto reticenti alcune
addirittura appunto a parte dire noi non
abbiamo mai scritto nel non sappiamo
scrivere ha veramente sembrava non
avessero niente da dire
ci sono stati momenti in cui è bastata
invece una parola la parola famosa parla
di lui c'è il famoso seme giusto per
farle aprire come un libro aperto
e chiaro che quelle che erano più
fresche chiamiamolo così di esperienza
traumatica per comunque la malattia è
un'esperienza traumatica avevano ancora
tanto bisogno di raccontare quello che
la malattia era stato ma è stato un
attimo perché poi il parlare tra pari
ed è quello che è stato anche la forza
di questo progetto queste sono le donne
dell'anno di quest'anno quindi abbiamo
marina antonella daniela sabrina emilia
noemi simona mara stefania e barbara
quella che la forza di questo lavoro che
stiamo facendo è il fatto che ci
parliamo tra pari e l'importanza di
parlare con qualcuno che ha attraversato
la tua stessa esperienza ha parlato a
stessa lingua
usa parole che tu conosci e ti permette
di usare le tue di conoscere quello che
sei tu e ovviamente anche cristina e
luisa che sono la matrice fondante di
questa di questo esperimento e voi quali
sono le vostre parole
io vorrei lasciarvi con un piccolo
esercizio da fare e regalate velo se
riuscite ogni giorno una piccola
meditazione che ciascuno di noi può fare
alla sera dopo essersi lavato i denti e
infilato il pigiama che è proprio
mettersi di fronte a chi siamo noi e
chiedersi se in quella giornata c'è
stata una cosa che abbiamo fatto che ci
è piaciuta davvero e andare a dormire
così pensando a quella cosa bella che ci
siamo regalati e se non ce la siamo
regalati quel giorno
promettiamo cd regalarci real giorno
dopo e magari annotiamo la e vediamo in
un anno quante cose belle ci siamo
regalati sicuramente non non ci farà del
male anzi renderà ogni giorno
molto più piacevole e forse questo
appuntamento alla sera potrà essere
veramente un'occasione per metterci di
fronte a noi stessi per quella che è
davvero la nostra bellezza e la nostra
unicità
perché questo che non ci dobbiamo
dimenticare in questa vita che va così
tanto di corsa che siamo unici e che non
siamo soltanto quello che facciamo ma
siamo qualcosa di meraviglioso che
brilla dentro di noi
grazie
[Applauso]